so there is a lot of hard physical
training that is harder depending on the
shape that you're in so when you get
there you have to go through a lot of
exercise few hours a day you know
hitting the weights at the gym then you
start with a specific training which is
testing everything from your ability to
withstand g-force to also just seeing
how you handle motion sickness and
disorientation they have something
they're called
that's nicknamed the spinning chair it's
called the vestibular chair and they
strap you in and they begin spinning you
very rapidly in one direction for about
a minute it's time and then they stop
and then they spin you really rapidly in
the other direction this goes on and on
for about 10 minutes another thing you
have to do is the centrifuge and the
centrifuge you sit inside of it it's a
couple hundred feet long fills an entire
big round building and you sit in the in
the front end of it and it spins at 200
miles per hour and it does 40 spins per
minute so this creates G's some people
describe it as just a feeling of being
crushed it's a very it's very difficult
to breathe you have to breathe in a very
specific way taking kind of shallow
breaths you know you can obviously can
pass out
you're also told not to open your mouth
because the pressure will actually
shatter your jaw then there's the vomit
comet which is basically the zero-g
flights so that's also something but
that's nicknamed the vomit comet because
people get sick and even even in just a
short period of time and the
weightlessness in addition to that
there's survival training they have to
go out to
near the Black Sea and and they have to
get basically they simulate if what
happens if you land in water and you
have to be in the capsule which is
incredibly cramped and small with your
two other crewmates and you've got to
you know slip in and out of your
spacesuit and get into your flotation
suit before you sink or encounter some
kind of problem a lot of the training
that the private space explorers are
doing is also just language you know
when they go up there they need to speak
Russian the manuals are in Russian so
that's tough especially for you know
Richard Garriott when he was in high
school he hated the idea of having to
study foreign language so much that he
actually gotten basic computer language
to count as a foreign language so now
he's over in Star City and has to base
it has to cram you know Russian in the
space of about eight months so it is a
pretty daunting task and it's crucial
because you know the fact is they're
hurtling through space he's one of three
people in this really small capsule and
needs to be able to not get in the way
you